em março de 1980 eu com 17 anos entrava
pela primeira vez recém formada em balé
crato vasco entrava pela primeira vez
numa sala de aula me deparando com quem
de rostinhos olhos arregalados ávidos
pelo mundo de novidade que eu abriria e
traria para elas e eu meus amigos em
pânico eu sentia que seu décimo um passo
a mais
eu cairia de cara no chão naquele piso
recém construído ainda chegando a
madeira fresca a minha vida e hoje me
preparado tanto para aquele momento
estudado tanto batalhado canto e nunca
me passou pela cabeça perguntar para os
meus professores como é que a via se
desce muito esse momento para cada um
agora era só comigo na minha cabeça
tinha um tento um crescente que eu não
consegui identificar se era minha voz ou
avós de da nossa senhora do balé
clássico pra me ajudar
enfim eu ainda depois dessa primeira
aula pela manhã eu ainda teria mais três
aulas naquele momento eu tinha que
enfrentar o ms
depois eu podia arrumar um jeito de de
sumir evaporar mas agora mudada
então eu respirei fundo e disse oi
centeno chão com elas e comecei a minha
carreira
coragem e desafios em que foram palavras
muito presentes na vida
hoje agora faço uso delas está aqui na
frente de vocês contando um pouco da
minha história acredita em mim está
sendo nada fácil
uma professora me disse certa vez eu não
sabia do quinto lugar é do 5º grau de
paletó
é uma lei divina em 8° oito níveis
diferentes
assim integral ok feito uma louca
estudam em cuba e é essa pessoa chega
pra mim e fala que não vai passar do
quinto grau ou disso
pense numa pessoa indignada com raiva
brava era eu mas ela sem saber que havia
provocado um turbilhão de sentimentos e
me levou a mostrar para ela e para mim
mesmo que o meu amor pela dança
revelados seriam superiores àquelas
intensa e com muita coragem eu fui
adiante depois daquela primeira
experiência em sala de aula as coisas
começaram a fluir com mais naturalidade
e tudo que eu aqui estudado agora fazer
sentido
minha confiança está crescendo mas a
busca por conhecimento me levava a
estudar cada vez mais
então eu procurei me unir com pessoas
que pudessem acrescentar indigência e
conhecimento também nessa época aqui em
cuiabá éramos apenas em três escolas e
foram anos e anos de estudo dentro e
fora do brasil até que um dia chegou o
momento de eu sair da minha zona de
conforto
um professor e bailarino muito querido
chega pra mim me lanço um desafio montar
primeiro balé de repertório clássico em
cuiabá
eu não pensei duas vezes
falei 'vamos mas eu tinha nessa
trajetória um monte de desafios que
iriam acontecer
geralmente esses baleias são montados a
partir de um corpo de baile já formado
naqueles oito anos de de aula
o meu corpo de maio que apenas 44 anos
a produção foi incrível e cenário do
teatro municipal de são paulo
figurinista os bailarinos convidados
técnicos na execução da angelina de som
e quase minhas alunas do 4º ano dando
conta totalmente do recado porque
orgulho eu sei
foi um desafio assim que é o sonho de
toda bailarina dança mulher de
repertório já havia dançado alguns mas
como escola no sul foi marcante para
prestar da cultura nessa cidade da
cultura clássica eu não me dava conta da
frente de trabalho que eu estava abrindo
trazendo essas pessoas de fora com as
quais vinham prestar serviço presente e
eu só me dei conta disso quando um
iluminador dessa casa o primeiro eu acho
que aqui trabalhou me confessou que
aprendeu muito com aqueles profissionais
que pediam nesse junto com esse projeto
além disso costureiras aderecistas
figurinista cenógrafo custos todos eles
de uma forma de outra também foram
contaminados por ézio hoje ele ea dança
antes de começar a falar de uma outra
faca fase da minha vida eu gostaria de
perguntar pra vocês
quem é que nunca de reunir um momento em
que as coisas parecem statham zerada
tudo redondinho e de repente surta e já
passou por isso sabe que as coisas
acontecem assim mesmo né
e foi assim que aconteceu comigo
mas o mais importante são as diligências
e as experiências que você tira um
momento de caos
minha paixão pela dança não me
permitiria ficar afastada por muito
tempo então eu quem é uma forma de sair
desse surto mental e voltar à vida com
tanto trabalho pela frente é a busca de
conhecimentos
a gente chegava a hora de eu me conhecer
melhor e não me conhecido que eu era
capaz de realizar mas de qual era o meu
lugar no mundo
eu coloquei uma reticência na minha vida
e mudei
num deles cidade mudei de profissão
mudei e com muita coragem
foi em frente eu havia sido miss mato
grosso e 1981 em quinto lugar no mesmo
horário e no mesmo ano aproveitando
algumas brechas
eu tirei essa partilha dos pés
calcei um salto alto e foi trabalhar na
joalheria
meu universo agora se resumia entre
pérolas esmeraldas e brilhantes quando
anteriormente era um piloto e todas 13
de máquinas e eu achei que poderia
deixar essa partilha guardadas no fundo
do armário por muito tempo que elas me
incomodar mas não demorou muito elas
estavam de novo dentro da bolsa
mas dessa vez tinha um diferencial
eu dançava e fazia aula só pra mim pelo
curu prazer de dançar sem é que produzir
nada ou para mostrar nada apenas pra mim
eu tenho e tenho que abrir um parente
dizer quando me formei a escola de
bailado de teatro municipal de são paulo
eu recebi alguns convites para dançar
profissionalmente mas como a situação
financeira da minha família naquela
época estava um pouco abalada não me rir
mesmo na obrigação de voltar para cuiabá
abre escola para ajudar aqueles que
tanto em tanto com tanto esforço o time
proporcionando sempre o melhor e foi o
que eu fiz foi trabalhar na escola então
não pude aceitar nenhum dos convites que
me proporcionasse essa vivência maior
show no palco só para mim
quando as coisas começaram a se
normalizar de novo à vida o rolando
'redondinha' eu conheci uma pessoa
incrível
e aí mais um desafio me mudar de cidade
por que ele morava em são paulo eu
morando em curitiba na época tinha que
tocar a relação valia a pena então eu
fui e aí uma nova cidade novas
conquistas novos desafios
mas eu fui em frente
é interessante como os momentos de de
caos na sua vida que levam por caminhos
que às vezes você nunca consegue
imaginar e e essa essa fase da minha
vida do caos mesmo estudo chamado de
idade média mas não é à toa que nem na
idade média foi um período
superprodutivo pra humanidade e eu acho
que também para mim foi foi de mais um
dia a surpresa eu descobri que estava
com câncer
em um mundo
aí will come exatamente como naquele
primeiro dia de aula
aquele tom na minha cabeça parecia um
mantra que dizia assim ea morte e água
e agora depois de algum tempo não sei
quanto eu percebi que o médico estava me
falando alguma coisa e ele vem com essa
todos o lenny todo com os condo ido até
pela minha situação e me dependentes
assim renan
se a gente tivesse que escolher um
câncer
escolheria esse que você tem de tirol
como assim esse foi o gancho e não
poderia escolher nenhum né
indignado eu estava brava revoltada
brava águida bratton todo pra minha
sombra é essa que está atrás de mim na
aba pensa em uma pessoa assim fora de
giro
era eu
e eu fiquei com um bom tempo assim muita
chata
já desde já mas era o tempo que eu
precisava pra mim fortalecer e para
lutar contra aquele
é mais um desafio na minha vida tudo que
te dizem a respeito de ter um câncer ou
uma doença séria é mundo ninguém que diz
da sua solidão do seu desespero da sua
incerteza do outro dia
nisso
isso a gente passa sozinho não existe
companheiro não existe família é você
com você não tem não tem outra forma
foram cinco anos de tratamento duas
cirurgias a anterior
maravilhoso o médico fala de alta
parece que o mundo sai das suas costas e
você começa a respirar de novo talvez
muitos de vocês deveriam saber que como
é esse vazio de não saber para onde de
ter que recomeçar né não saber por
ônibus e agora fazer o que eu tinha
parado cinco anos fazer o que eu voltei
pra minha terra para as minhas origens
para perto da minha família
o exalando trabalhado nessa
no sesc e me convidou para implantar a
área de dança do sesc e no final estava
sendo inaugurado um baita desafio super
difícil porque pra quem é da área de
realização da ação da linha de frente é
muito difícil você está sentado atrás de
uma mesa fazendo requerimento e
requisição para comprar um quilo de ver
eu passava sapatilha
mas vamos lá era mais um desafio a
conseguir e eu gostei muito do que eu vi
ali aquele movimento de dança
mas eu queria estar mais próxima de tudo
isso eu queria poder realizar de novo eu
esqueci de comentar e daquela primeira
leva de alunos
duas alunas foram fisgadas por esse amor
pela dança e montar a escola de de valer
e um outro aluno fez carreira no teatro
guaíra como bailarino e posteriormente
como coreógrafo
eu me lembro da meu orgulho de quando eu
fui assisti lo e do meu orgulho que eu
tenho por cada aluno um passou pela
minha mão
independente do que ele se tornado eu
acho que eu recebi muito mais do que eu
dei
mas é um orgulho e news
todos eles na mão fui convidada por uma
dessas dessas vezes alunas a integrar o
quadro de professores mais um desafio
voltar à sala de aula dando aula na
criancinha de 3 até o corpo de baile
adulto tem hoje sete turmas e foi com
muita mas muita coragem que eu aceitei
esse desafio
eu mudei meu caminho
diversas vezes
e olha é preciso muito mas muita coragem
pra você sair da sua estrada mas como
também é preciso uma coragem e cunha
para você voltar para ela outra se
reinventado na outra uma outra dimensão
pensado será mas os desafios estão aí
pra isso não se colocar em cheque ou
mesmo começando de novo outra vez mais
uma vez mudando título num enfrentar os
desafios
hoje eu completo 56 anos 37 e desde
aquela primeira vez que eu entrei em
sala de aula com aquele tom o outono meu
saber se lembrando que o quase
prejudicar nenhuma nem dano nenhuma
frustração em uma linha um pouco mais de
coragem
isso eu termino minha fala hoje contra
vocês da minha experiência de ataque
hoje àquele ponto em que sempre me
acompanha
eu acho que é uma orquestra ambulante
que vai junto comigo assim ele estava na
minha cabeça dessa mesma versão que
escala a banda marcial
obrigado pelas avisada mas então eu
respirei fundo
[Aplausos]